hier meine lieben villiger und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft heute am dienstag bevor ich
anfangen mit den fans muss noch kurz ein
paar wochen sagen jetzt geht ganz
schnell ich fasse mich auch sehr schnell
und ich rede auch sehr schnell
jedenfalls wenn ihr das video gerade
schaut wenig unterwegs sind zwar bin ich
vier tage reise ich so ein bisschen
durch deutschland deutlich über also ein
paar termine habe und jetzt einfach auf
diesen zeitraum gelegt habe videos sind
allerdings vor produziert das macht euch
da keine sorgen allerdings da ich am
vorproduzieren bin kann ich natürlich
kein geheimnis von das geräusch dran
nehmen und dass wir dann einfach wieder
nächste woche dienstag kommen also das
war sache nummer eins ich sagen wollte
in sachen nummer zwei ist dass ich mit
meinem kumpel jerome eine minecraft
animation gemacht habe und zwar von
einem wein ihr kennt eventuell facebook
war einst diese fünf bis 15 sekunden
langen videos die total kurz und wo
einfach witzige sachen passieren
wir haben gedacht wir machen das ganze
mal in minecraft wollt ihr dass ich
davon einfach mal eine folge hochladen
bei wärme mehrere folgen gemacht und ich
würde die dann einfach irgendwie morgen
abend hochladen also am mittwochabend
und gebt einfach mal daumen hoch
beziehungsweise schreibt bitte die
kommentare wenn ihr sowas sehen wollt
und sonst mit dieser anfang märz den
text wird auf jeden fall bis zum ende
dran bleiben weil ich euch noch geht die
kritik coole sachen zeige wie man ein
lagerfeuer bauen kann man viele andere
dinge
und dann fangen wir seit ich mal an erst
effekt ist mir nämlich halt selbst
eingefallen und zur hälfte hat die mir
auch einen tom per mail zugesendet und
zwar meinte tom dass man auf einem
schild 1 mm was ja ein relativ breiter
buchstaben bis zum rand schreiben kann
allerdings nicht bis zum rand schreiben
kann also er meint dass das ganze von
den buchstaben begrenzt und nicht von
der buchstaben breite allerdings ist es
in der 1.8 zu ich weiß nicht ob es nicht
innerhalb von sieben punkte schon sehr
weh tun ich habe hier ca so dreimal so
viele ihs wm geschrieben oder ich kann
das hier beispielsweise auch mal mit
ausrufezeichen machen oder jeweils in
einer parade buchstaben mit dem w das
ganze geht nicht kommen das geht nicht
von denen mit der breite von den
buchstaben enger zusammen sondern
wirklich ein fall das hängt mit der
breite von buchstaben zusammen und nicht
von wie viele buchstaben buchstaben ich
schreibe also diesmal meter 2 zugesendet
allerdings ist das gegenteil der fall
und das jetzt konnte das allererste mal
dass ich ein fact angenommen habe der
eigentlich falsch ist und den quasi die
client
aber abgelehnt also es geht auf jeden
fall ich weiß ich glaube sogar es ging
damals nicht so ich weiß dass es damals
zuging
mit dieser welle das habe ich mal
gezeigt dass die über das schild
hinausgeht allerdings ist das ganze
jetzt irgendwie mehr oder weniger
gefixed wollen wenn jeder genaueres ist
schreibt zum bikini vernünftig in die
kommentare
und das wort perfekt nummer eins und
jetzt compact nummer 2 der dritte weg
wurde mir zugesendet von star craig und
zwar weil der held von kräftig aber
infekt für dich den definitiv kaum einer
kennt
wenn du folgendes im singleplayer
nietzsche dann gibt's gift von crafter
barry 1 bekommst du ein item was im
inventar wie ein durchgestrichener kreis
aussieht wenn euch die letzte folge
änderte habe ich nämlich gezeigt dass es
ein alter gibt was köcher über sein
köcher ist den es in minecraft noch
nicht wirklich gibt und dann habe ich
gedacht das ist eigentlich dieses
durchgestrichen rote ding ist dieses
durchgestrichen rote ding ist allerdings
ein barrier das heißt ich schreibe
schrägstrich gif leerzeichen ihrem namen
also bei mir konkreter leerzeichen
leerzeichen 1 dann drücke ich enter und
ihr seht schon ich habe hier so ein
rotes dingen um mich dass die hinsetze
seht ihr erstmal gar nichts und ich habe
quasi ein unsichtbares also ich weiß
nicht genau was das ganze soll ich kann
auf jeden fall gegen laufen allerdings
ich kann auch drauf springen bleibt bin
ich hier drauf beispielsweise die sache
ist dass dieses ding also dazu gibt es
ein paar trivia sachen die mir sagen
jedes teil so ausmachen mehr oder
weniger da könnte ich keine mops drauf
spawn also ich kann theoretisch eine
ganz riesige fläche machen und da kann
dann nicht irgendwie monster drauf spawn
oder auch keine schweine oder und was
auch sehr sehr cool dass man kann damit
unsichtbare wände machen irgendwelchen
adventure märz beispielsweise dieser
barrier leitet nämlich letzter und ich
blende euch jetzt mal eben ein bild
davon ein wie das ganze teil redstone
leid und da kann man auf jeden fall
richtig richtig richtig richtig coole
irgendwelche sachen die unsichtbar
weitergeleitet werden machen bei
adventures et cetera pp und das war auf
jeden fall fällt nummer zwei ein
unsichtbares in minecraft
der dritte fakt ist dass man keinen
rüstung ständer irgendwie in love oder
wasser platzieren kann also ich kann
jetzt rechtsklick drauf machen das ganze
funktioniert nicht auch im wasser nicht
es geht allerdings wenn ich dann einen 2
block hosting mache ich setze da mal hin
und dann rutschte da einfach runter bei
lava ist das ganze auf der fall
allerdings hat das ding dann also diese
rüstung ständer natürlich zum großteil
aus holz ist und dann verschwindet er
nach der zeit
und dann ist ja quasi im wasser drin und
wenn das ganze wasser fließen würde das
heißt ich mache jetzt beispielsweise mal
einfach so bau den rüstungs stände ab
nehme jetzt hier ein wenig ruhe und
jetzt setzt sich den rüstungs schneller
da rein dann fliesst der sogar mit der
strömung mit und damit kann man richtig
richtig coole sachen machen ihr seht
nämlich schon wenn ich die teile hier
mal reinsetzen wassers dafür eine
konstruktion wird das sieht nämlich
schon so ein bisschen sehr sehr sehr
sehr cool aus und das ganze leitet
nämlich jetzt schon weiter zu dem
vierten fällt zudem ihr nämlich jetzt
mal kommen und zwar wurde mit der vierte
effekt zugesendet von klaus und zwar
meint er dass man hier mit was ich grad
schon gezeigt hat einen wunderbar coolen
rüstung stände rüstungs stelle ein
wunderbares lagerfeuer machen kann
ich setze mal ein paar rainer mit ihnen
etwas wie das ganze funktioniert wir
haben jetzt nämlich hier durch die
strömung so ganz ganz viele rüstung
stendals kann man die nachher mit lafer
anzünden kurz dann tritt das teil
nämlich weiter
und dann kann man da so blöcke darüber
bauen mit pisten die einander
eingedrückt werden dann hat man ein
lagerfeuer aber damit ihr genau wisst
was ich meine und wie man das ganze baut
hat er mir auch ein video daran gegangen
was ich mir gedacht habe wenn er das
extra indien sind um 23 minuten video
alles aufbaut für mich muss ich das ganz
einfach mal einblenden deswegen blende
ich euch jetzt das ganze einfach mal ein
damit ihr euch das ein bisschen
anschauen können wie das ganze
funktioniert wie machen sie musik ein
bisschen lauter oder das video ein
bisschen schneller damit ihr seht das
ganze klappt und das war auf jeden fall
viel danke an dich klaus
fact nummer fünf und damit auch der
letzte weg für diese folge wurde mir
zugesendet von lukas und zwar meint er
dass ich keinen schalter oben auf eine
stufe platzieren kann
wenn ich allerdings mal so mache ist ein
schalter darauf dass manche allerdings
nicht sondern er meint wenn ich diesen
schalter nun drücken möchte dann geht
dieser schalter einfach weg der
verschwindet einfach der fliegt dann
einfach weg als ich mit dem creative
deswegen habe ich jetzt quasi zwei also
im zweifel natürlich die dann einfach
wieder bekommen und das ganze hängt
damit zusammen einfach auch wenn ich
beispielsweise auf diese platte recht
darauf mache geht der schalter
automatisch an der wand weil er genau
weiß okay
auf der platte da bin ich nicht gekommen
und zwar wenn er hier keinen block
irgendwie näher hat das heißt wenn ich
jetzt beispiel wenn ich jetzt hier
irgendwie sondern einen ganzen block
irgendwie dran hecke dreiecke dran dann
hätte dann wird er automatisch daran
gehen und dann könnte ich noch hier ganz
normal aktivieren allerdings auf einer
stufe geht er automatisch kaputt ich
finde es ein bisschen doof weil wenn ich
theoretisch mein ganzes haus diesen hart
blogs machen würde weil auf hartplatz
bonn ja keine monster wie man
bekanntlich weiß und dann wäre ganz
einfach kann ich da keinen schalter am
boden platzieren ist auf jeden fall ein
bisschen verstehe ich nicht so ganz aber
das war der fünfte effekt und das war es
auch schon wieder mit den heutigen micro
facts meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich definitiv
bei einer bewertung freuen
ich hoffe dass ihr die meisten dinge und
ich kannte wenn ihr allerdings selber
sachen wisst wie ich vorstellen könnte
per mail an kontrakte gmail.com und dann
würde ich sagen sehen wir uns in einem
anderen video bieten